voilà il ya internet je suis connecté
avec la boxe machin il ya aussi word
excel un ordinateur plutôt attendue du
matériel informatique qui a manqué à
johan et ses frères et soeurs pendant le
confinement
jusqu'à présent il travaillait avec un
téléphone portable via la bvk plus de
devoirs et c'est un peu plus compliqué à
à les expliquer c'est pas comme à
l'école on est des parents beaucoup
c'est pas facile de les expliquer qu'on
les profs le fond c'est l'enfant qui
essaye de contrôler un ordinateur donné
par une association catholique le rocher
oasis des cités travaillent sur les
mureaux depuis 2010 quatre familles sont
aujourd'hui équipés sur la commune
l'idée c'était de voilà on a on a fait
un une sorte de recensement on va dire
des différentes familles avec lesquelles
le rocher en lien et il nous a semblé
pertinent de fournir ces ordinateurs la
aux familles qui avaient des soucis
aulas dans laquelle il y avait plusieurs
enfants à faire travailler des familles
avec lesquelles on avait aussi un lien
construit dans le temps
voilà c'est des enfants qui sont
accompagnés par le rocher depuis
plusieurs années maintenant
un don qui s'accompagne d'une formation
informatique joël ne retournera pas à
l'école d'ici la fin de cette année
scolaire
sur l'ensemble de ses activités
l'association soutien jusqu'à 400
familles